[Musique]
bonjour top 10 bonjour secrétaire
général du rassemblement démocratique
pour la martinique le rdr merci d'être
avec nous dans son caddie samedi
prochain jour de vote au premier tour
des législatives avec votre formation
claude liste qui sera présent dans le
centre atlantique et sur fort de france
marie-france tous les christian vernet à
travers eux quel est le message du père
10 m face aux autres candidats via j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure qu'il y avait un
vide sidéral de cette campagne et je ne
suis pas loin de penser ça mais il ya
quand même des candidats qui meublent ce
vide avec de la matière réflexions ont
divisé les honneurs sous dos à nos
candidats d'abord se réfère des valeurs
lesquels sont des candidats de je dirais
delà du socialisme authentique c'est à
dire pas du socialisme qui a viré depuis
quelque temps au néolibéralisme rang y
donne il donne la primauté à des valeurs
de solidarité de mise de l'homme au
centre du développement économique et
pour nous c'est pas l'économie n'est pas
l'homme n'est pas au service de
l'économie de l'économie est au service
de l'homme et nous ne sommes pas pour le
tout marché
nous estimons que tout n'est pas
marchandises alors ça paraît vous y avez
sa barre et les honneurs et ses sofas
clairement nationalité que va s'employer
à la bataille non et deuxièmement non
ils défendent d'abord des idées mais ce
sont des personnalités qui ont reçu une
formation qui ont des convictions qui se
présente avec comme jeudi une carte
d'identité politique dans ce pays où
maintenant il ya un flou dans beaucoup
de beaucoup de zone du champ politique
là ils sont clairement identifiables et
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure qu'il n'ya
plus de distinction entre autonomistes
indépendantistes exo l'éditorial de jean
brad hand ou c'est vrai que beaucoup en
sont là c'est à dire qu'il ne veut plus
parler à la population d'une vision
d'avenir alors c'est difficile c'est
difficile pour le rdr de porter ce
message là lorsqu'on voit
la cacophonie porté par une grande
majorité des candidats non encore dit
non nous nous faisons de la pédagogie
politique depuis que nous existons nous
faisons de la pédagogie politique
nous sommes clairement pour une
responsabilité locale
alanguie l'autonomie on sait pas ce que
c'est oui oui bon bah c'est c'est le
fait d'avoir un certain nombre de
responsabilités mais que le peuple
accepte d'avoir alors il l'a refusée
lors du débat 73-74 c'était justement
l'ouverture vers plus de responsabilités
locales
aujourd'hui on voit que beaucoup
réclament par exemple une priorité à
l'emploi local ce que les corsos vont
peut-être obtenir sans débat 73 74 et
nous nous sommes enfermés dans ce débat
là c'est pour cela que nous sommes pour
une révision de la constitution non pas
pour aller comme d'autres vers une
troisième voie obscur d'automne c'est
par où elle peut mener mais nous voulons
simplement que l'on naît un article qui
permettent le deux âges à la demande et
selon les aspirations de chaque peuple
d'outre-mer un dosage des
responsabilités que l'on souhaite ce
sera la mission de marie-france trop
dure à gravir des six unités
ce n'est pas assez l'une des missions
bien entendu il y à des urgences
nous nous distinguons ce qu'il y a lieu
d'aller demander tout de suite alors
exemple à bien par exemple c'est un
ballon d'oxygène je dirais financier
pour les collectivités territoriales qui
sont exemple pourquoi parce que vous
savez que dans l'hexagone les
collectivités pèsent environ 73 % de
l'investissement public non militaire
donc l'autonomiste si vous êtes leurs
jeunes à linosa nous à nous et à et
morbecque nous c'est plus de 85%
donc il faut ce ballon d'oxygène pour
l'investissement je dis bien peau ou
permettent plus d'investissements des
collectivités
c'est très important pour l'emploi et
puis il faut absolument que l'état que
l'état corrige le système de reste un
change un sursis sur ses propres
allocations vous savez qu'il ya plus de
57 millions d'euros alors
que l'état laisse à charge donc en fait
c'est une dette de l'état sur le rsa et
l'apa donc il y a des demandes pour les
hôpitaux tout à l'heure j'ai entendu là
le grand crû de 3 2 3 il est mais c'est
tous nos hôpitaux à commencer par le chu
il faut absolument les remettre à niveau
il faut les doter convenablement c'est
la santé des martiniquais le logement il
faut une grande politique notamment pour
la réhabilitation
ça c'est des urgences et puis il ya il
ya une grande loi de programmation à
mettre en chantier
là c'est là c'est le plus long terme est
aussi un projet éducatif martinique et
alors claude lise on dit souvent que
lorsqu'on va à la législative aux
législatives
c'est souvent pour certains candidats
l'occasion de compter ses voix
ce n'est pas du tout la langue non non
non c'est pas notre préoccupation
important un message et puis alors il
faut que les citoyens réagissent au
pressage comporte également des messages
quand également le message de jean luc
mélenchon de la france est soumise
pendant la présidentielle
ce n'aurait pas été plus simple de
réaliser par exemple des tickets des duo
gagnant avec les candidats de la france
est soumise pour cette liste hâtive là
par exemple christian verneuil avec la
géraldine de toroguhé marie-france
rallier notre sécurité nous nous nous ne
nous ne sommes inféodés à aucun parti
national voyez nous avons appelé à voter
mélenchon premier tout parce que nous
voulions d'abord un faire barrage à
marine le pen et 2 nous voulions qu'il y
à une opposition en crée véritablement à
gauche
vu la dérive néolibérale d'une bonne
partie de la gauche donc maintenant nous
ne sommes pas forcément d'accord avec
tout toutes les mesures mais sans permis
d'y voir plus clair
non non nous nous tenons à cette
indépendance et si nos candidats sont
élus ce que je souhaite évidemment ils
iront siéger non pas au sein d'une
formation politique française comme
adhérent
ils seront apparentées savez moi j'ai
été tout le temps apparenté au parti
socialiste comme c est apparenté au
parti socialiste mais
ça nous a toujours laissé une assez
grande liberté d'action savait que moi
je n'ai pas voté onze jeunes et le
d'efficacité selon certains il faut
faire partie de tout mais pas du tout on
attendait franchement atlanta et ça va
empêcher d'être à l'origine de la loi
d'orientation pour une autre mère qui a
tant apporté à nous payer d'outre-mer ça
m'a empêché de faire la réforme des a
dit y compris contre martine aubry qui
était pourtant dans un gouvernement que
je soutenais ça m'a empêché d'obtenir
des textes importants sur la la
coopération régionale et ses graines non
pas du tout moi je crois que précisément
il faut être déterminé
il faut donner le sentiment que l'on
sait ce que l'on veut mais bien entendu
il faut aussi avoir un ancrage local
suffisant c'est pour cela que je demande
aux martinique aux martiniquais
lorsqu'ils ont fait leur choix et bien
de faire en sorte que les députés qu'ils
envoient et bien soit élu avec beaucoup
de voix c'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont
représentatifs comme lise l'idée
générale c'est quand même vrai me dire
si vous êtes d'accord avec cette
impression que partage pas mal de
martinique m et bien que les candidats
qui sont actuellement poste à
l'assemblée de martinique au conseil
exécutif ne font guère honneur au mandat
qui est le leur depuis décembre 2015
beaucoup de martin qui ne comprennent
pas cette cet acharnement à en vouloir
encore plus non moi je crois qu'il ya
des des élus qui à un moment donné
estime qu'ils seront peut-être plus
efficace au niveau national français au
parlement que là où ils sont mais c'est
lourd doit ce qui serait même s'ils
prennent au rachat qui se disent qu'ils
seraient sa mairie quelques mois ce qui
sera critiqué ces s'il voulait cumulé
systématiquement un moment où on demande
de plus en plus d'éviter de le faire
surtout qu'en réalité il y a des
responsabilités et pour autant tu as
assumé localement mais que l'on décide
que finalement on sera mieux ailleurs
écoutez si ce n'est même pas vous
ressentirez des droits tv par exemple ce
que vous avez comme cette casquette de
voir que tant de collègues
de votre famille politique ou bien de
l'autre côté vous passez à la pose
problème ça pose problème parce qu'on a
un exécutif réduit à neuf personnes
dassault systèmes qui n'est pas fait
pour la gestion
moi vous savez que je suis de ceux qui
disent qu'on nourrit dû être un peu
comme la guyane c'est à dire avoir un
président un une commission permanente
est ce qu'on appelait la commission
permanente qui existe dans les
départements et des régions
et là vous avez beaucoup plus de
vice-président de membres du bureau etc
qui partagent l'exécutif et l'opposition
en prison je pense que ce système
dans le cas de l'actuelle serait le
meilleur parce qu'on nous a donné une
gouvernance qui est une gouvernance qui
n'avait véritablement de sens que si
l'on est justement d'un système
d'autonomie comme la polynésie voir la
nouvelle calédonie donc aujourd'hui le
fait que vous ayez une concentration du
pouvoir exécutif dont peu de mains ça
entraîne le fait qu'on disait b 6 6 1 ou
2 s'en vont ce sera catastrophique donc
là aussi nous voulons d'ailleurs j'ai
oublié de le dire demander de corriger
ce texte
merci claude lise on rappelle que cette
secrétaire général du rassemblement
démocratique pour la martinique et et
que vous avez deux candidats en lice
pour les législatives de samedi prochain
1er tour merci bonne journée si bien
[Musique]
et